ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show happy father's day i'm
calling my father
for the first time on the show we
haven't spoken in a few months both of
us very busy
and we're calling him for the first time
on the program
very excited about that have you do you
call your father tomorrow
yeah i'll see my dad actually does
hunter biden call his father tomorrow
i bet he does hunter biden is joe
biden's son
he's the uh the roger clinton
uh the wild brother kind of the black
sheep the neil bush
as you would say of the family
reading a article now from the new york
post it says hunter biden called asians
quote yellow in text exchange with
cousin but the text exchange is a little
creepy
it's weird yeah and people are
speculating they're saying is this human
trafficking
this is the text exchange and do we know
who hunter is
is he the blue he's the blue i believe
so this is the text exchange somebody
says
she's a legend none of these women are
except for diva
d-e-v-a deva diva but nikola
deva and ella and lucy and
all know quality girls who like i am
are distrusting and highly highly wary
of evil
i also have denise to german 26.
somebody writes no to lucy i think
that's what hunter hunter yeah hunter
writes no to lucy
somebody writes okay so fine do you want
foreign or domestic
hunter goes and you have to make the
pitch directly
this is hunter i can't give you a
blip ing asian sorry i'm not doing it
hunter goes domesticated foreigner is
fine
then the person says i'd give you
isabella but she has kids
and an nba ex-husband and then hunter
biden goes no yellow
and somebody goes yes mina and that's it
do we know what this is i mean this
might somebody might just be setting him
up with an escort
it's speculative but this is from
caroline biden his cousin
i don't know if it's human trafficking
it could be just
an escort it could be human trafficking
it could be we don't know
and what is caroline biden is leaking
this
uh i think this is all from hunter's
laptop they're recovering all the text
messages where is this laptop i don't
know
where is it i don't know i mean
this guy let's be very honest
is fun i guess the daily mail has it
looks like it they have the laptop
so this guy for people that don't know
abandoned the laptop
to get it fixed in delaware in delaware
and he wasn't thinking because he uses
drugs
and everything is apparently on this
laptop
i mean ufo footage human trafficking
the nuclear codes the launch codes i
mean supposedly everything that you
could
ever want to know about any conspiracy
is somehow on this laptop i'm
obviously being facetious about that but
there are
some things on the laptop he probably
doesn't want out so the daily mail has
his laptop
his cousin's attractive huh yeah he'd
[ __ ] his cousin
you know that thought has crossed his
head hunter and the cousin
so now he says uh racial slurs because
he's a crack addict yeah
so but now now like this is the problem
with
uh you know rabid political ideology
is that now conservatives are trying to
cancel this crackhead
based on text messages he sent while he
was smoking crack
so that's what conservatives are doing
instead of going we got we kind of got
duped by trump
the q and on movement i mean it's not
doing great
uh it's seen better days we kind of get
duped
the immigration of the borders worse
than it's ever been online censorship
is is ratcheting up but we'll talk about
that later
no none of the goals were really
accomplished during the trump
administration when you had a republican
congress and senate and whatever quote
unquote whatever you want to call it the
cancel
culture the blah blah blah uh on
universities and in corporate america
has seemingly
gotten worse that being said republicans
in order to fight that
have decided to
find instances where hunter biden the
president's crackhead son
has used racial slurs he called his
white attorney the n-word
he called his white attorney the n-word
that's how conservatives are trying to
get back in power
by proving that hunter biden a crack
addict
has said the n-word we know he has
i mean i'm more interested in what the
[ __ ] was going on in the text threat
i mean maybe they're just setting them
up with an escort i'm all for that
but it's very interesting when he goes
you want foreign or domestic
that's cute but it does sound
interesting and he goes i'd give you
isabella but she has
kids well i don't know why does that
matter
if it's her job right something's going
on
what is what do you mean i'd give you
isabella but she has kids
and don't go queuing on like oh he's
trying to make her disappear i don't
really think that's happening
um i think what he's probably trying to
do
is he wants a chick
and maybe he just said i don't want
anyone with kids maybe he specified that
like i want an escort that doesn't have
chill although i don't feel like hunter
biden
is making is that drawing that moral
line in the sand
but i don't know maybe hunter biden is
saying
hey i can't get off if i know she's got
kids at home
and an nba ex-husband so that's another
thing
i could get yeah but i don't want i see
he's a big deal
he's a little famous ex-nba husband so
maybe you can't [ __ ] around with her and
hang out she's got kids and it could get
real
sticky i think that's what the guy's
telling him this could be a sticky
situation
if i set you up with this chick it's not
gonna be good
your dad's trying to be the president or
thinks he might be the president
so this is not good so hunter goes no
yellow
and it's racist and he's also you know i
don't know
i don't know what's going on here but
i know that there
no one cares about any of this and i
don't really care about any of it either
i don't care what hunter biden
i mean you could turn up anything about
hunter biden i would not be shocked like
there would be
no story about hunter biden that at this
point would currently
throw me off my access access like if
you told me if you said
hey so they found on hunter biden's
laptop
uh that hunter biden
uh was actually the reason reason that
that malaysian plane went
down it was him and he parachuted out
i would go what they go remember the
malaysian plane that disa
that was hunter biden there's a video of
it on his laptop he's parachuting out
and i'd go oh all right like there's
there's there's no huge
like there's no like shock in awe
this is a crack addict when someone is
doing crack
you imagine they're going to be involved
in
hijinks that's what he was involved in
some hijinks
and some uh tomfoolery you'd imagine
that he's uh
smoking crack how disappointing to be
smoking crack
and to not be getting escorts and he
should have the pick of the litter
um what is so weird the guy goes i can't
give you blank asian sorry i'm not doing
it
and you and the hunter goes you have to
make the pitch drug it's such a weird
way to get an escort it's such an odd
way when hunter goes you have to make
the pitch directly which i kind of
understand hunter is like listen i don't
want to
pick you have to pitch this woman to
what i want
before she's got to show up and know
what the deal is
how much do i owe you 100 biden asked
some guy
how much do i owe you before adding
because blank
n-word you better not be charging me
hennessy rates
i mean hunter
oh that was also with caroline
yeah wait a second
for the chat with caroline ask mesures
okay
i wonder why the cousin is like getting
him escorts too like what
well i don't i don't know if the cousin
is
i don't know what's going on
however hunter's father has his own
history of usually racially charged
language towards south asian people
remarking in 2006 that you cannot go to
a 7-eleven or a dunkin donuts unless you
have a slight indian accent
yeah people are forgetting that joe
biden's been like a racist forever
like joe biden remember when he said um
he referred to the inner cities as
jungles
what did he mean by that biden's been
a kind of a good old boy delaware racist
forever i mean now you know obviously
he said obama's the first good clean
articulate black guy
to run for president this is biden i
mean this is what he does right
we've all forgotten about that that's
fine you might think he was a lesser of
two evils but
don't forget that biden pops off as well
and um the content of the message
suggests that it took place after 100
pot and ended his relationship with
haley biden
the widow of his older brother beau
that's a special guy
who starts [ __ ] your dead brother's
wife
immediately and what is her deal
this is what i mean about these are the
people running the country
you know dave smith made a point on
rogan where it was like you had epstein
you had hillary clinton running for the
presidency her aide huma
abedin her aide is was married to
anthony weiner
sexual predator hillary's husband is
bill clinton
sexual predator it's like how many
sexual predators
are in your day-to-day life i mean
that's a fair question when you look at
the bidens what the [ __ ]
is going on hunter biden smoking crack
and then starts [ __ ] his dead
brother's
widow like immediately
and then after that ends he's like
getting escorts and
i mean is a wild man
i mean i don't know
but that that's what happens
in these families
whether it's the bushes or the clintons
or the bidens you you don't know much
about the inner dynamics of
of any of these families most of what
you know is a completely manufactured
narrative
that is spun uh by pr
people and uh
the media and by the time you find
out who these people really are
they [ __ ] you ten different ways
by the time you unearth the information
that you should have had
to make the decisions about
whether they should get the job or not
you're in deep [ __ ] it's true
by the time you figure out who george w
bush
really is you're in uh two wars
you've got two wars and you've lost all
your civil liberties
that's what happened this is another
article i love hunter biden's artwork
he's actually good and will be worth a
lot
well drugs help he's selling some pieces
for half a million
of course he is can you imagine the
people walking around going that's an
original hunter biden
i get more and more marxist every day on
the show
and i have make more and more money
because what i'm starting to realize is
that if you have
the money to spend half a million
dollars on an original
work of hunter biden crackhead
and putting it up in your mansion you
maybe shouldn't have the money
it's true also i mean i i put up a
satirical
uh thing on instagram the other day they
take it down
we send it to our friend in vc it's a
joke i said i'm osama bin laden i'm not
dead
i'm i'm get i'm i'm getting into an
energy drink and we're entering the
first round of fundraising
and it's called bomb energy and you know
i did a lot of jokes i said
and um can we pull it up you think let's
read the email
that instagram took down which is
clearly satirical
and this is why i'm getting frustrated
everyone hates the way i say that word i
say
frustrated but it's frustrated with
capitalism because you would think
capitalism has all these badasses to go
[ __ ] you it makes money right but what
it really is is a lot of people
that are [ __ ] and they're rolling
over because
10 people on twitter get offended at
something i know
all these badasses supposedly these cold
heartless capitalists
they're all rolling over uh and
capitulating to like
it used to be like this mob of weird
evangelical soccer moms
that would be like we don't want marilyn
manson performing in pittsburgh
and now it's like
[ __ ] uh a few thousand people on
twitter that get angry about anything
and these billion dollar corporations
and these ceos worth a hundred million
dollar
they just roll the [ __ ] over cause
they're terrified
well what the [ __ ] the point
i mean at the end of the day didn't
stalin just kill these people without a
problem
to the gulag maybe that's where i
ideologically end up
saying well you know what everyone gets
to go to the gulag
let's pull this email up that we sent to
our friend
who's a friend of ours he's a young kid
in vc
and we said dear frederick my name is
osama bin laden
many people think i am dead that is not
true i'm alive and well
and i'm very excited about the energy
drink space
we have come up with a caffeine-free
antioxidant packed energy drink
called bomb energy which promotes
overall health
while stimulating the consumer in a
sustainable and vital manner
we are beginning to raise capital and
are hoping for a 9 11 launch date
which i had nothing to do with by the
way we're very interested in partnering
with your venture
to take bomb energy to the next level
our slogan
is bomb energy the jews run the world
initial focus groups have been very
responsive to the slogan mind you
many of them have been done in the arab
world we're looking to potentially
soften our messaging
as we take bomb energy
mainstream and that is why we believe
you a squishy bagel face
are the right person to help us in this
endeavor we are committed
to increasing our market share in the
ever-expanding market
of health and nutrition we thought this
project would interest you
a little zionist doughboy we look
forward to hearing from you and working
together
and then we say we also have heard
positive things about uh patrick
finnegan hopefully you can connect us
who's a
a venture guy in new york who's on
clubhouse who we knew and then i said
best regards osama ceo of bomb energy
and instagram took this off
i don't know why it's supposedly it's an
algorithm that identifies
words how but there's a lot of words
that are criticizing zionism and i'm
making a joke
some i guess jews or or bin laden
i think it's the bin laden thing it said
when they took it off it said
an association with dangerous groups
right
so i
am just getting a little i'm a little
i'm a little listen
we all know capitalism has this lion's
share of problems
but we never anticipated that one of
them that would be that the
ceos of companies are too sensitive
and it and that's my issue now
it's one of them i would like people to
have health care and i would like them
to afford buying a house
but i would also like if you're gonna be
a capitalist pig
be one and tell people to shut the [ __ ]
up go
dude the guy's got a certain amount of
followers
he's a comedian it says comedian in the
thing i'm not gonna whine about this the
whole episode because it's boring and we
get it
but they're trying to kick the
weinsteins off and you know me and the
weinsteins are just
deeply in love with each other and
here's what i'll say about the
weinsteins they should
i think they're smart and i think they
should be able to say whatever they want
to say on youtube
i don't care what they're talking about
whether it's the voting or the migration
patterns of bees
or whatever it it doesn't matter to me
and i think they make a lot of sense
when they stick to science and
evolutionary biology because that's what
you do
and i think they should be able to do it
and i want to hear what they have to say
about the vaccine and what they have to
say about ivor mets or whatever the [ __ ]
it is
i i'm i'm not talking about it because i
don't know anything about it
i got the vaccine because i want to go
to london and suck off somebody
with who's uncut who has the with the
when the skin is over the head of the
penis and i can't do it
if i'm in uh america well i can't i
would
did it once it was not for me but i
figured british would be better
and then you could have the roast have
the roast on sundays with the peas that
they mash up it's not a great food
country but
they have uh the uh the indians very
good the chicken tikka marsala
my point is this i wasn't like the
vaccine is here
i didn't change my name to vaccine on
twitter like some mentally deranged
people i know
i got the vaccine because i thought i
would need it to do my job and i would i
will i know
to go anywhere and to do anything but
listen i want to know
about everything and i think it's good
for society when you look at how fast
that labley hypothesis went from a
conspiracy
to a mainstream news where jon stewart
is on colbert saying hey guys
he's saying the exact same thing that
the weinsteins were saying six
[ __ ] months ago to their credit to
brett's credit and to heather hein's
credit
and i have no closer friends than those
two but
uh and i like them they're just a little
is a little sensitive but
i think they're spot on with a a lot of
that stuff
and they should be able to go into i
don't need to i don't need expertise on
everything that's ever
happened but i think this is this is
their [ __ ] turf
and to get them off youtube is [ __ ] up
but no one cares
so there's gonna need to be an
alternative there's gonna need to be an
alternative to youtube there's gonna
need to be an alternative
um to to a lot of these social media
sites i don't know who's going to do it
or who's going to come up with it but
there's going to be after it's going to
have to be an alternative and it got to
be 20 million
can we get spotify on the phone by the
way can we get them on the phone right
now because i'm a little
i'm a little heated we have the core
daddy girl get
60 million dollars uh to talk about anal
joe rogan gets 100 million dollars to
talk about aliens and bigfoot
and tim dillon who is really covering
everything uh gets nothing
the greatest podcast right now the tim
dillon show has been offered
zero dollars from spotify zero dollars
but we've got uh joe rogan and uh that
uh call her daddy alex so what i'd like
to do
is i'd like to call spotify and i would
like to request
20 million dollars and that's what the
show is worth
yes when we've done the metrics we got a
lot of people listening here
so i would like to 20 million dollars
from spot is there no number
we can call a number now why can't we
call because they
they don't have people working and it's
just an email that they get back to you
like years later
this is absurd i'm trying to see if i
can find a foreign number to call
call them in sweden where that guy lives
the ceo
i think he lives in switzerland or
sweden or something should we go there
maybe we should just go there i'm
talking to an attractive guy from
holland
he's got blonde hair he speaks funny
sounds like a fish
um this is is this brick call that
england okay
see if they answer that call that
connector i've had enough of not getting
what i want but my point is that you
shouldn't have with the kind of
disposable income
where you and who wants hunter biden's
[ __ ] artwork
that junkie he's moved to l.a what is he
what did he what does he paint his dead
widow's puss what is he painting
this is the article hunter biden laying
low in l.a starting art career with
shady dealer
i gotta be honest is it it's hard not to
like him
i'm trying not to like him can you
dislike him no it's very difficult to
dislike him
it's very difficult he's in la where
we'll be back there
eventually oh in the fall and uh maybe
we'll get him on the show
and uh he's he's becoming an artist
great
he's doing impressionist work let's
let's see if we could get through to
these people because quite frankly or
code you have dialed is incorrect
well what is that that's the spotify
general info
number thanks [ __ ] them
we're taking our show off spotify i
think oh really i think we're going to
do that
we have a lot of listeners on there yeah
but there are a lot of people i think
that's the best thing to do
okay because then maybe they'll give us
a big offer which they won't but
it seems like when the shows go to
spotify they're not as big is that true
yeah i know one guy at spotify but he
just quit so
we could call him though who mike who is
he
he's uh he's over at a different company
now but he wasn't spotify can you call
him yeah yeah
call him i'll call him they call him
right now
i want 20 million dollars
you find his email what if i did a
podcast with hunter biden
can can we call spotify and tell them
that we'll do a podcast with hunter
biden called
the laptop where we go through his
laptop and we play videos of him
painting all the women he's tortured
i think that's a good idea
we'll stop every now and then to read an
ad for blue chew
and then we'll go back to going over all
the red rooms that hunter biden has
spent time and
you know eli roth hostile style taking a
[ __ ] drill to some woman's eye
and we'll discuss that it's an
interesting life he's an interesting guy
okay here's mike he should have a
podcast
we should tell him if he answers he's on
the show yeah
he listens to the show so he'd be fine
with it doesn't mean we can record him
without his consent
he's not answering no one works you know
oh it's saturday i guess yeah well what
does that mean
what does that mean money doesn't flow
another clown i love keeps one of my
good friends is experiencing hair loss
and i put them on to keeps
the greatest thing about keeps is it
offers a simple stress free way to keep
your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications disavowed
delivered straight to your door every
three months you don't have to leave
your home
they're low cost discreet packaging they
have more star
five star reviews than any of their
competitors prevention is key
what keeps does ben is it allows you to
keep the hair that you have on your head
it stops hair loss immediately and they
take four to six months to see results
so act fast
it's so much better than you know
getting hair plugs
uh which that comic who doesn't like me
we think you got them right
yeah so yeah weird uh also
you know any of these other uh
things you don't want to do that no you
don't want to do that you want to use
keeps you
keep the hair you have if you're ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
to k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash tim dillon receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash tim dillon to get your first month
free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dillon
i'm telling you folks you're gonna need
your hair
it's the summer of fun out there you
want to start
preventing hair loss now so that you're
not
bald by the time you finally start to do
well in life
two out of three men are going to
experience hair loss by the time they're
50 million men in the u.s more suffer
from male pattern baldness
only two fda approved medications that
can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dillon my friend loves
it
i'm telling you it's the best thing i
ever did for him
sheath underwear it's the best underwear
you can use it as a bathing suit it has
a pouch for your [ __ ] and balls
the inventor robert patron checked the
story it's very interesting he was the
person who tortured chelsea manning
right after chelsea manning um
leaked the information that we were
randomly massacring civilians
chelsea manning was tortured in a small
cell robert patron
did that he tortured chelsea manning
every day
for this country sheath underwear dot
com you saved 20
if you use the promo code tim uh he's a
real
deal [ __ ] military guy
who was involved in some of the craziest
secret missions we're just starting to
find out details of these
missions now um um operation burn an
orphanage um amazing where what they did
was they landed and
they lit an orphanage on fire and then
everybody ran out of their house to see
to help they rescue the babies and then
they also shot them
um operation withhold medicine from sick
children
where your child would go to the doctor
to get medicine but instead
robert patron would be there and he
would put a gun in the doctor's mouth
and say don't give this kid medication
until the parent tells us everything we
need to know so some of these incredibly
vital missions the robert patriots i'm
proud to support sheath underwear.com
s-h-e-a-t-h sheath underwear.com
a nice little pouch for your [ __ ] and
balls prevents chafing it's great for
this summer
robert patron is one of the reasons
truly one of the reasons that america
does not recognize
uh the uh legitimacy of the war crimes
tribunal in the hague the international
criminal court
uh because of robert patron's actions
and we're so proud of him
he's uh one of the reasons that
the united to any u.n st
uh condemning degrading inhuman and
cruel treatment of prisoners robert
patron
um you know in iraq he made quite a name
for himself the butcher of baghdad some
said
okay the raper of riyadh because he
would go to saudi arabia
and rape men and women on they're our
ally he just did that for fun
they call him the rape of riyadh the
butcher of baghdad and he started an
underwear company
she's underwear.com used promo code tim
to save 20
let's go to victoria's secret now
victoria's secret is
getting rid of the angels and they're
replacing with megan rappano
the uh uh lesbian soccer player
and uh who dan carney went once for
as her for halloween and he he looks
like her you can't do that now anymore
that'd be good upset about that probably
victoria's secret assigned soccer world
cup winner megan rapinoe and actress
priyanka chopra jonas oh she's married
to nick jonas or one of the jonas's
joe jonas maybe victoria's secret assign
yeah we just did that um the blaggered
lingerie giant is relaunching and moving
away
from traditionally real thin models by
introducing the vs collective
with diverse leading icons and change
makers including jonas and rapano to
shape the future of the brand
but don't expect to see white tigers
star chopra and rapido who've been a
preeminent voice in the fight
for women's equal pay in the soccer
world posing in the firm's
famously flimsy barely their briefs
we are told they're both being hired as
spokeswoman and will instead appear on a
podcast
and then marketing materials for the
recovering brand
so victoria's secret is not doing well
as a brand supposedly and they've
decided that
what they should do is get rid of the
angels and the attractive women and
bring in women that may be attractive
but are different shapes
i don't care about this really
um i i think
with the availability of online porn
i don't know that straight men care that
much
about the victoria's secret angels right
right it seems kind of a quaint archaic
yeah
it seems like a quaint and cute idea
but if if
if guys can go online with a click of a
finger
see barely legal college girls choke
down
[ __ ] and then take shots to the face
and then
you know orgies and gang bangs and
chicks getting waterboarded
and strangled and people bleeding on
each other and scat
bdsm people getting tied up choked out
punched
fingered in their eye you know people
just i mean do we
do does anyone really i think the war on
the standard of beauty
is you know not the direction i'd like
to see the world go in
i think it's an unrealistic standard of
beauty but lots of things are
unrealistic right
none of us are gonna have uh a house in
the hamptons
or a maybach but is it do we now have to
say that those things are not desirable
of course there's trade-offs to having
those things
maybe you have to work harder maybe you
have to hollow yourself
out maybe you'll never have real friends
maybe
you'll have to be skeptical of everyone
around you deeply paranoid
maybe you have to arrange your emotions
uh in
in in the way that a serial killer would
in order to move up the ladder in
whatever organization that's paying you
the type of money
to have those things i don't know but to
say
that on their face a beach house in the
hamptons or a maybach
is not a nice thing to have is
ridiculous and to say that a
skinny body with big tits or a skinny
body with a big dick
is not nice to have even though it's
unrealistic for most people
the idea that as a as is standard and
not a standard that people have to
attain
but there's a standard to just look at
and go huh that's nice
you know when you walk around a locker
room and you see a guy
when i was a swimmer for years and you
see a guy with a big soft penis
which is rare i mean a big soft
i don't mean like like oh it's visible i
mean like it hangs
and it just flows in the wind that when
you go
even a heterosexual guy goes yeah that
might be fun to have
and who knows i don't know maybe there's
downsides to that i'm sure there are
whatever you know
man spreading i don't know uh that being
said
um there's very few people that look at
a penis like that
and go well i'm i don't want to give
that a shot
and i don't mean that you don't have to
suck it but i mean like having it
most people look at the pillar when a
woman sees another woman who's thin and
has
big tits perkins you go i would like to
take that for a spin for a week
go you know what i'd like to look like
that for a little bit let's see what
it's like
it's the truth and
truth now is an inconvenient al gore
but it's it people are it's uh
it's but it's troubles people when you
say things that are true that doesn't
mean
hey good-looking people a lot of times
they're better not as good as
people that are like decent looking like
all day loans
meaning that it's not prime credit but
it's pretty good
they [ __ ] better usually than people
that are insanely good looking because
insanely good looking people a lot of
times are just they're
you know they're not really givers or
thinking about themselves and they're
not there and
nothing going on in their head and
whatever they're not they're not
passionate people
so some of these people it's not even
sexual
when you look at some of these things
you go i don't know even though if it's
sexual some of it is
but it's just a standard of beauty
i always looked at models and i was like
they're not always sexual but there's a
beauty to them
and that doesn't mean that fat people
can't be beautiful and people
fro with the scars can't be beautiful
and people in wheelchairs can't be
beautiful and
all of that is true and people with the
flesh-eating bacteria
necrotizing fasciitis can be beautiful
or people that
don't have arms or legs or just kind of
a torso
they can be beautiful and people that
are you know
dead and kind of having rigor mortis set
in where
their body is starting to rot it smells
bad they can
be beautiful it's not to say that
somebody who half of their face is
missing because they fell asleep
and their house went on fire can't be
beautiful they can be beautiful
it doesn't mean that somebody whose eyes
have been both gouged out
uh can't be beautiful because you can
put glass ones in it doesn't mean that
somebody
with a fungus that has eaten the
majority of their vaginal area
can't be beautiful and they had that
surgery it doesn't mean that it doesn't
mean that
somebody who is like a a centaur which
is half horse
half burst it can be beautiful they have
a big horse [ __ ] you jerk it off
it smells a little weird and it's furry
but they can be beautiful it doesn't
mean that a fawn
can be beautiful which is a half goat
half human it doesn't mean that somebody
who's a thousand pounds
can be beautiful and that has a little
bit of a rash on the innards of their
anus
that has turned into this you know pus
filled things that are very very big and
they explode
every time they take your [ __ ] it
doesn't mean they can't be beautiful it
doesn't mean
somebody with the type of psoriasis that
is it's almost like a dinosaur's skin
the scales
are and they flake off and they're so
rough that they can actually cut your
skin
if you touch them it doesn't mean they
can't be beautiful
what it means is that there's a little
bit of a standard that's widely
recognized
as a nice looking
that's all we saw a gentleman today at
brunch who had
was was he was not white which is nice
was uh hispanic and had shaggy hair
it was a very nice you go that's a
good-looking person
that's a good-looking person if that
person
was six or seven hundred pounds bigger
than they are now
it might hurt the look
it may not i don't know but
they and they weren't thin that that guy
was not thin right
he was like lean it was lean there was
no six pack right but there was a lean
assume
but i mean what i'm saying is that
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
that's that's my point and i and i hope
victoria's secret figures it out i just
what i think is gonna happen and there's
nothing wrong with this is just
the victoria's secret fashion show is
gonna start and they're just gonna start
in wheelchairs rolling out
people with flesh-eating diseases and
that's okay i'm for that i don't care
i don't care i'm for that this affects
me
uh not at all it affects hunter biden
ship station a lot of people are making
money online i'm telling you right now
the economy is about to crash online
commerce is the way to go
if you're running a business you don't
want to spend time focusing on shipping
that's why no matter what you're selling
amazon etsy your own website ship
station funnels
all your orders into one simple
interface you can manage from anywhere
even your cell phone
we use shipstation and we love it it's
easy they work with all the major
carriers ups fedex usps
easily compare carriers and choose the
best solution every time if you have an
online business ship stations small
businesses can access
the same rates usually reserved for
fortune 500 companies without the
contracts or commitments
ship more in less time just use my offer
code tim dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-o-n to get a
60-day free trial
if you're starting a business or
entering uh into a new
part of your business having a 60-day
free trial is huge it is big
two months free it's just profit baby no
hassle stress free shipping go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in tim dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
that's shipstation.com enter offer code
tim dillon t-i-m-t-i-l-l-o-n make ship
happen s-h-i-p
make ship happen after spending the
summer on the sidelines we're all ready
to get back out there and make this
season's lounge season is an epic one
bespoke post is here to take your sans
sun and surf game to the next level i
love these things
box of awesome i send them to people
it's a great gift to send somebody
instead of buying a gift you could get
them a year subscription a box of
awesome
and you could cancel any time it's free
to sign up you can skip a month or
cancel any time
each box costs 45 but it has 70 dollars
worth of gear inside it's a great way to
get someone to gift it every single
month
they're they're reminded you got them a
gift truly
20 off your first monthly box you can
curate it if they're a dude and they
want outdoor gear and
grooming goods and travel stuff it's got
cool little stuff
about having a home bar or whatever if
they're into different things it's
really really cool you can curate it to
their interest
box of awesome.com under the code tim
dillon i've gotten this now for a few
people
as a gift and they all call me and go
thank you every month which i like
it's not just a one and done gratitude
it's all the time they go
hey man thank you and if they skip a
month you can kind of develop an
a grudge and i like that too but they
just keep
thanking you and recognizing that you
gave them a gift
every single month box of awesome.com
enter the code tim dillon at checkout
20 off your first box get it for
yourself get it for others
how great is it uh 45 and you do that
for the whole year
it's nothing and you got a you give
somebody the whole year
it's great if your son or daughter is
going off to college this is amazing to
do for them
okay if uh somebody you know is moving
away you go hey we've created
this cool box you're gonna get in the
mail every month it's great for somebody
with a new house new apartment going to
school
it's amazing 20 off your first monthly
box all these things sponsor the tim
dillon show
we appreciate that so helping them helps
us go to tim dillon to check out 20
off your first box box of awesome.com
book of mormon uh which is do you know
my second cousin wrote this
or my third cousin oh really this guy
robert lopez who's like kind of related
to me but really not related to me
and him and his wife probably want
nothing to do with me they're new york
uh
theater people theatre people
a book of mormon the tony winning
musical uh comedy by trey parker matt
stone and robert lopez so he's the
he's the music he writes the music he
wrote uh let it go
for trojan he wrote to music for frozen
he wrote avenue q
um the show's a reverend depiction of
africans has been much discussed topic
in theater circles since matters
of broadway's entrenched racism took on
a renewed scrutiny followed last
summer's blm protest in a people tv
interview
original cast member josh gad asked
about a potential film adaptation said
i don't know that the show could open
today and have the same sort of open arm
response that it did then
it's not to say that it's less
significant or wonderful or incredible
as a musical
i just think the nature of the art to
adapt
isn't it a book about mormons who are
ridiculous yeah
these people believe in magical
underwear and that the bible is
uh dictated to a guy named joseph smith
that was like staying in a holiday inn
or something yeah yeah
so the whole musical
is a brilliant satire about how insane
that is correct to a degree right
and they i guess they also they're
they're slightly tone deaf when it comes
to africans because it's satirizing
mormons correct
who are probably racist
yeah right yeah that's the whole point
right the whole point is for you to go
look how ridiculous right look how
absurd
not well they got a point right but
that's the fear
the fear is that people go there and
they sit down in a broadway theater in
the middle of manhattan and go
yep they're right they're right about
black people they're wrong about
everything else they believe about
magical underwear and joseph smith it
was like some drunk
who came up with some dumb like they're
they're wrong about all that and the
temple you have to go
yeah they're wrong about all that so
it's absurd to me this system was the
most successful
broadway show in you know other than
hamilton in like history book of mormon
was
so incredibly successful nobody
was upset at book of mormon it was
widely understood
that this was a parody of people that
believed
absurd things okay
and now people are going we have to
adapt correct
we have to change it it's interesting
when you look at trey parker and matt
stone who are probably the most
brilliant satirists
of our time and political social
commentary nobody really does it better
and people going let's change it let's
take a step
back and let's change it
and i don't know it just seems like it
it's never ending
and then in the heights comes out
lin-manuel miranda people go well
there's colorism
uh the latin people are not afro-latino
i don't know
listen you know
at the end of the day it's like
it's a great quote we're letting the
perfect become the enemy of the good
if it is good to have more
representation which i think it is
it's clearly good as long as it's based
on talent right
merit and finding people that are really
good at what they do
and not softening uh the entire space to
where you're elevating mediocre people
based solely on uh
you know box checking but if if if you
have people that are super
talented which in many cases they do
this is a great positive thing but let's
not let the perfect become the enemy of
the good
nothing's going to be and it's it's also
whose idea is perfect we don't know what
perfect
is but certain people's idea of like
everything has to check every box and be
the most
and it's like we're losing art can't
function like that
it can't it just simply cannot and all
the people that dismiss these concerns
and go like this is all old people that
are like hey i
i can't go on stage and hate transgender
people anymore
sure there's an element of that but i
think the
more you know reasonable
people are saying all these things are
a net positive diversity different
voices
different stories things like that it
matters how it's done and
it matters that the art is first the
comedy's first
whatever you're doing happens to be
first and
you're not pathologizing everything
into a political statement you're making
something great and including other
people
for no other reason than the fact that
they enrich the the work and make it
better
it's crazy that essential never had an
asian person on
it's crazy that they didn't have a black
woman i've said that black women are
probably the naturally funniest group of
people
over a certain age usually over 40. but
it's crazy that essential but it's all
these white
liberal uh you know harvard guys that
all you people want to be ruled by all
the time
all you people they seem to escape as
long as you're a tall
ivy league white guy you seem to get out
of the you seem to have that and they
everybody still you know builds a statue
to you on the temple mount
um i don't cast snl you know they
probably had some blind spots
they certainly did but you know we've
taken it to a level here where it's
you know where it's getting absurd
you know you know if every single story
just has to have the most mark the most
marginalized people
truly are dead people
right they're not alive they don't have
the privilege of
even drawing breath so if we take this
to its logical conclusion
we're all necrophiliacs because if
you're alive there's some level of
privilege in being alive
so if we're just gonna do if we're just
going to have
we're just gonna we're gonna have to put
a bunch of corpses in a room
and call it the christmas story
if if that's what we're really gonna do
because now people are like well you
have you're ableist you can walk
you're neurotypical you're not autistic
you're cisgendered so you're the gender
that you were born as
you're straight you're not queer
you're you know so so again we just
we're going
down the line here and it just seems a
little ridiculous
and and we all know that and there's
really no way out of it per se
so that's why there'll probably be some
type of
uh there's a split happening and it's
pretty big
the people that are on tv right now that
have their own shows have far less
followers
on twitter and instagram than i do and
other people that are online
one of the reasons for that is the
eyeballs are leaving tv and they're
going to the internet
how do people try to colonize the
internet what a word
colonize we don't know but
it's coming it's coming
and you see the split and the people
that are on one side of the split are in
a fit of rage
i don't care i can enjoy shows like
hacks on hbo
i'd say they're fun shows but
a lot of the same people in that part of
the entertainment business
are somehow angry that there's people
online
that have money and that have a
following uh
and the people in the media that work
for
major corporations and networks are
angry that there are people that are on
sub stack
writing and having a following so you
see a theme here
you see this decentralization happening
and a lot of people are
not happy about it there's a lot of
people that are angry about it
and they're going to do something they
keep
trying to do something the problem is
the money is with us for the moment the
the
people want the content we have the
freedom right now
and it's making money because it
resonates with people because we can do
what within reason what we want to do
and we hope it stays like that you know
but if not
i will with hunter biden start
a podcast and it will be great
bill moore he's he's a lot of great
takes it's just too much of a get off my
lawn energy
like a lot of his takes are good it's
just couched in a
and again it's my same thing it's like
him kimmel
fallon colbert just go yeah yeah just go
you've been around for too long you did
it you had it we
we have the same these these networks
are terrified of replacing these people
they try to literally sing it bombed
they try they're
they're terrified they're terrified of
what
the new late-night shows will look like
because of everything i just mentioned
but give me one
give shane gillis one give nick mullen
wouldn't it be great
wouldn't it be great you want to see
that guy that writer the
uh cessnaming when she's head melt
i get a late night show shane gillis
gets one and nick mullen gets one
you want to see like just heads
his head just completely melts but
we're on tour caroline sold out five
shows within uh a few hours we're really
excited about that
we've got other dates too we've got so
many the merch is over sunday at
midnight so today
when this comes out you've got one more
day for fake business for the pink the
yellow
any of the fake business merch also the
tim dillon show
t-shirts hoodies uh the the flash drive
just sold out 20 for the flash drive
that was a little excessive
um the fake business thermos
the fake business white hot
the fake business notebook is sold out
and also that other things
okay well yeah they're all sold out
except for the shirts
the real good stuff the hats get it
i'm telling you right now it's great for
the fall i know it's party summer but
the fall is coming folks
that's a killer summer shirt but the
fall is coming and hunter biden's going
to pick up that rock again
and he's going to make some great art
where do you want to be when you hear
hunter biden crash his car
on the middle of melrose i want to be
sitting in my fake business
hoodie in the fall where do you want to
be when hunter biden
oh deez i mean dude do you think biden
they've hired your secret service to
like camp out outside of his house
um look at that coffee brown tim dillon
show hoodie i like that one a lot does
it get better than that
what do you have planned for katie's
parents uh we're gonna go golfing
tomorrow oh
nice and did you tell them you're
leaving
yeah eventually and they and what did
they say they said uh we know ben's
worked very hard and
we what's great about these texas
families this is what i've learned about
texas people i'm gonna i'm gonna give
some compliments now
because and by the way the only i'm
never sitting on text i'm shooting on
austin which i like texas a lot
i like dallas i like people with big
hair and really cool pools and hot days
and
that kind of like you know that that bus
boy today was like latin but not
that's the whole thing now and i don't
mean but not like
if you know i'm saying it's that mixing
is nice
everybody likes it right everybody likes
it oh the mashed potatoes and the gravy
the point is what i'm saying is that
these texas families stay out of your
[ __ ] business
they stay the [ __ ] out long island
people
are loud obnoxious
nosy just in your [ __ ] business
in your life your name is in their mouth
all the time these texas families just
by seeing ben's family and katie's
family
they are just stoic ranch people
and it is so important they just let
their kids live their lives they respect
them they go
we raise good kids they're gonna go out
and live their lives
we are independent don't you feel that
yeah they're like just be independent
that's great that is a [ __ ] texas
long island is just this thing where
they go we want
to control you and we want to
give you our opinion all the time and we
want and it's just
[ __ ] and i really appreciate this
texas
you know freedom it's about freedom yeah
your aunt will call
you and talk you out of decisions you
haven't even made yeah she'll be like
hey
if you're thinking about it don't do
this because but in fairness
i will do that to others yeah but i'm
right
i have that long island thing too where
i will call people and tell them what to
do
and how to live but i'm
correct i guess she thinks she's right
that's the problem but she's not
but i am
denver comedy works i try to get tickets
we're trying to open them up in full cap
the 23rd through the 27th it's the only
time i'm gonna be in denver for a while
we're trying to open this club up try to
get tickets keep trying
because every day they're adding more
tickets raleigh north carolina the 8th
through the 10th new york city caroline
sold out 15 to the 17th boston
massachusetts wilbur theater
there are some tickets left july 21st
through the
23rd foxwoods casino in connecticut
there are tickets left on the 24th a few
of them irvine we're adding shows
keep checking even if you heard or saw
that one of them is sold out
capacity is constantly being updated
tickets are constantly being added
irvine california the 29th through the
31st
san diego california the 12th through
the 14th american comedy code las vegas
that's a music festival
if you're if you're there at the
festival you want to buy a ticket to
that i'm doing an hour there
um why is that on there twice
uh because you're also doing the i think
you're doing two shows you're doing
house of blues and then you're doing
this as well
am i i think i thought it was one show
we'll we'll have to figure that out
we'll call our agent he's uh
probably at brunch he's at torrey pines
right now oh yeah what watching us open
yeah you're so jealous
you just hear like it's very quiet on
the green and then you just hear him
with a potato chip
and who are they they're all there like
brooks captain all the way there
yeah brooks bubba what's up here in the
green
and we're just we're just waiting
start asian eating chicago illinois the
24th
through the 28th we're trying to open
that up too lori lightfoot to menace
grab tickets to that thursday september
baltimore
the 23rd to the 25th milwaukee october
7th through the 9th and then we got
other stuff as well
that we're taking a little sabbatical i
think and
then we're gonna start our move back to
the
what is california called the sunshine
the golden state the golden state
yeah and then uh caroline's did it sell
out completely i believe caroline just
sold out
also i'll be at joe rogan's comedy
extravaganza the club
in austin joe rogan's comedy hut it is
me the lineup is sick it's me
brody stevens gary chandling
joan rivers it is an insane and bob
schimmel
so it's robert schimmel gary shandling
joan rivers brody stevens and tim dillon
at uh joe rogan's comedy hut in austin
now
let's and you know i have not spoken to
my father in
almost three months so for father's day
i thought it'd be very nice
to call my father on the show
let's give him a ring and we'll see what
happens
i'm not spoken to my dad in two months
it's almost three
hey slot oh my god you caught me at the
weirdest time
oh my god my slave is here and he's like
with the scripts and he's being
dominatrix it's insane hold on one
second
oh my god he wants me to sit on this
nutribullet
oh my god hi
hi dad happy father's day how are you
hey flop so i'm doing pretty bad i'm
just stuck here with my slave and he's
flipped the script and he's seeing my
dominatrix
it's insane so i don't understand so
he you usually dominate him oh my god
yes he's tired of the slave he's being
[ __ ] crazy right now
oh my god he wants me to sit on this
nutribullet again
you think i should do it should i do
oh my god by the way how's school hold
on one second
i sit down oh my god oh my god jimmy i'm
so scared
it's the big cup okay hold on
yes oh my god
oh jesus christ it smells like alyssa
milano's [ __ ] in here
oh my god it's fun though thank you so
much for calling i mean
how are you it's good is this safe is
everything you're doing safe
oh my god please don't worry this
happens all the time here
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] he just hit me in the
[ __ ] with a pan
oh my god this is crazy
this is like a service that you you have
come to your home
oh my god yes listen enough about me how
are you how's austin do you like it i
i'm
you know it's an adjustment i think i'm
going back to la i think it's more my
screen
beautiful what are you saying it's
beautiful and austin and the talent
there oh my god
timothy stay give it a chance i i don't
think i can
i am not putting that down the garbage
compactor oh my god
timothy is this a bad time no no
why don't i call you back it's a great
it's a great time uh i just want to wish
you every father you know we hadn't
talked in a while i wanted to make sure
that everything was okay
yeah this i'm is sitting on that
oh my god timothy it's your high school
trophy i
cherished that no let's sit on it is
this okay timothy
yes if if you have to do it you can do
it we've got to lube it up i have to
he's
he's in charge i'm supposed to charge up
and saying
oh my god you did so good on the soccer
tournament
okay i've got the head i'm down
by the waist oh timothy i'm so sorry i
know you love this
we'll clean it up yeah oh god well
i'm glad you're having a good weekend
thank you so much for calling it's so
sweet
and i hope you and you know this power
dynamic between
you and the dominatrix i hope you guys
figure that out
oh my god i hope it flips up some points
oh god thank you so much for calling and
thank you for the flowers it's so sweet
yes well well you're you're i appreciate
it and give them to your wife
oh my god i have to go timothy but god
bless you for calling yes thank you
happy father's day
sweetheart good luck at school thank you
that is
my father um
um he seems well
he seems like he's doing it he's doing
the right thing and
you know um
you know hey
just happy that he's doing well yeah he
seems good
he's very good okay well happy father's
day to everyone out there and i hope
your dad is
having as much fun as mine